en creux tout le monde se retrouve sur
la vidéo de fifa 12 en compagnie de mon
ami squeeze alors on est sur fifa 12
donc moi j'ai pris l'om il a pris mais
moi j'ai pris dans la mise à prix miles
à moi j'ai pris marseille autrement dit
l'eau à moraliser leurs pilotes par les
insurgés
et je dois dire que d'habitude pour l'om
attendons mais je connais pas les
faucheurs une âme et ses chants gros je
croise et or on attend mais celle qui
aime moi non mais moi à merde
les mecs c'est moi le ah oui voilà une
artiste à part ça c'est pour une passe
vraiment longue ça c'est pour tirer
enfin de passes courtes c'est pour faire
une balle en profondeur
ok ça marche après du concours du court
attendez il faut donc comment je cours
comment je cours un tu cours avec il ne
gâchait pas être un bâtard tu me dis pas
comment tout rire c'est que genre une
gâchette seule la wii la sérié je crois
alors sachez que moi on est rude pour
paris nous savons tous que si la paris
et georges c'est une commande pour saab
en deux buts de messi pour pai donc j'y
vais faire ici et là je comprenais ces
bassins à l'éolien cours tempête de
merde oui c'est quoi pour tirer c'est
quoi peut tirer c'est quoi ta pas fait
ça huawei c'est ce week end
c'est carré un carré de playstation ou
salon stade de projet oui mais non mais
j'aime pas je croyais que c'était
triangle pour tirer moi je dis un
tricheur
moi je dis à tous quoi de quoi tu m'as
des penaltys ah non c'est toi avec ta
[ __ ] c'est quoi ce héros l'instant
c'est toi c'est quoi bon c'est pour
faire des petits trucs mais c'est quoi
ton spectacle dans les jambes ou écouter
de façon démarche des augustins oui gaye
stevie n'ai jamais osé le combat n'avait
pas 17 matches 1 0
auteur d'un triplé une bombe à cela
n'est pas ce [ __ ] je vois comment déjà
tu parles bien et que tu fais à mes
madame et moi cet art c'est ça les
changera chez jouer mon jeu roche mais
voyez le guide ddfp être moi tu fais une
passe en profondeur que cela crée en vue
d'accords mais non mais non c'est moi
s'il te plaît elle voyez comme il est
mauvais joueur à jay z égale mauvais
joueur moi je vous le dis à jay z
également mes joueurs
[Musique]
il est où pastore c'est pas vrai y'a
papa story de [ __ ] mais je voulais pas
centré sait comment faire 2 passes et 1
a aussi à pastore je les sais quoi pour
faire passer un seynois cx un cx de
playstation long ces [ __ ]
alléluia le moteur de collisions nommé
tard oui oui oui des faits car et non
pas les gens à aller là bas je suis
tellement concentré il avait accordé
tellement je suis à fond dans le match
commence c'est le conférencier n'a pas
précisé si la non nécessité une touche
allons le faire de belle aux points 108
morts vous avez vu le but mais il a fait
tout le terrain ah mais je suis un dieu
mais [ __ ] et passez moi cette idée les
cheveux barria abbas a laissé tranquille
de même chez moi comme on la passe moi
passe à la ceni [ __ ] mais aussi tue
pas mais aller à nantes 2 90e plaît je
veux te plaire non puisque là je sais
pas c'est quoi les tout est sûr c'est
qu'après une passe
à pour faire mais c'est ça c'est ça ça
pour ça pour centrer sa partie récemment
fait remarquer alors pour faire tester
la profondeur
ouais ouais non mais comment est
franchement les produits failli devenir
trouvé tellement naze non oh merde
attaque lui et me donne la balle et
ouais hein
j'aurais pu intercepter georgette
comment tu tacle au oui au pastore il
est technique assez souvent c'est moi
qui fais juste et adéquate mais non mais
c'est pas vu je vais la faire mais ça on
a vu comment tu t'appelles a comme ça
aille à 0 0 mais d'amener messieurs mais
quoi mais tu pues bas n'empêche que je
me bats toi mais je vois un mais
pourquoi dès que je fais une passe en
profondeur et que les loups et à jour
techniquement oui à mai ces dames vous
allez voir je vais lui rentrer un joueur
répond pas tu fais
alors oui oui oui elle a pu le diable
elle demande alors non eh oui qu'est
c'est un haut niveau commente harris se
bat non je suis dégoûté alors attendez
on va adopter une stratégie plus
défensive le célèbre regarder
[Musique]
non au oui on a pas je l'avais vu je
l'avais vu que tu te casses le cucquois
[ __ ] elle peut faire l'outil la faire
rester vraiment à ce que moi je suis
auto quoi toujours un nom c'est moi qui
fais une fois deux fois
voilà ça cobra sakho yes yes casque uni
alors attendez moi d'ailleurs
chantome il fait tout homme il fait la
passe les néo lensois oui quel tacle de
cris et je m'en excuse
joris d'avant centre
c'est historique
[Musique]
non mais je suis pas tiré les penaltys
choix c'est grave ce le prix ouais mec
je vais aller vers la gauche
je te promets de vous tirer en même
temps ouais c'est ça qui cherchait à
caen j'ai trouvé mes cheveux un poteau
hockey m'a tuer l'ennui
non je te plaît non c'était plus
dénoncés pour la mayral à moi non mais
je te plait pas cibler ce matelas
chaises tables
[Musique]
alors à droite du boulet doit aller la
tête là mais ça c'est bien
marseille s tu as le commentaire est
vraiment mieux s and mail art du caesar
sanna leproux il ya pas stilic vous
n'avez pas être franchement quitte pas
ça m'énerve
si face à minerve
je suis nul berlin j'avoue qu'il est
bien fait quand même le genre qu'est le
respect des terminaux à l'expéditeur
mais qu'il y avait là conflit qui
travaille à la poste veut déjà tu parles
plus que je ferai grâce à un ace sur le
t j'avoue que jamais que j'ai pas tacler
non non on arrête tout akpa genre le mec
qui me bloque combler deux mais je
croyais un truc pour tirer le maillot
jaune
assez assez limité ok ok 3 0 pour elles
les aident les gens je suis dans la
merde je suis littéralement dans la
merde [ __ ] on n'arrive même pas à
commenter tech3 ouais moi aussi je suis
sûr que tu as qui fut la non ce fait
pour ce mois là bas qu'en ce moment
c'est une merde tu vas me mouiller là
même au lit c'est normal normal c'est à
faire aller voir ce petit trois ans que
oui 1
alors vas toi avec toi je vais marquer
mais mettez pas sérieux foot approché
pour marquer je sais pas dans les films
arizona que dans fifa 2002 où je me suis
un peu crue dans celle d'une chaudière
de tacler comme huawei ça se bat non tu
as et marca
tiens on attendait les gens ont
l'habitude
qui n'a pas déjà fait vous m vers le
jury et quoi tu fais moi j'ai fait pas
de bien celle utilisée en tout cas on
espère que cette vidéo fallait parce que
beaucoup de plaisir à 3-0 à ce coup ci
petit plaisir à commenter vos est roi
qu'attendez mais non mais non mais non
mais certaines y en ait trois à l'esa
mérité un petit but et algo de même car
je sais pas pour quelle équipe vous êtes
lui ouais mais je dois dire que ça mais
je pense que c'est évident j'aime perdre
des abonnés à m
genre un sport de [ __ ]
chifa est un sport fifa est un sport ce
jeune armée attendant les vrais
magiciens pas faute pour ça je suis
désolé dans le meck franchir le cap et
dario c'est énorme
j'ai relevé qu'il accepte utile en
défense il fonctionne et qu'il a un
carton jaune lui non non elle te plaît
antoine est selon marca le fait non
seulement
oui oui oui oui oui
non mais pourquoi comment tu fais pour
lomé je suis pas moi aussi j'en attends
attends et je vais me concentrer dans le
corps des parce que là franchement on
espère en tout cas manger avec du pop
corn dans cette vidéo sinon ça au papier
ouais c'est clair il ya des énormes
blanc passionnant il ya des blancs même
temps on est trois font mouche en
découle un temps c'est un peu l'ambiance
d'un sommet à paris marseille a battu
marc avec le bol mais que je me mets du
tout sur youtube en dieu n'aime pas
moins la chaussure est un abonné cafaro
[ __ ] j'aimerais bien qu'ils voient
alors bien qui marquèrent de gaulle
pastore là j'ai bien je suis pas pour
l'om mais quand même parce que je la
fasse jour là pour calculer passe en
profondeur ainsi que là bas et dans
l'ensemble je suis très troublé up poker
tac tac tac tac et pierre ensuite
antispam prayssas et non c'était
vraiment
à el jadida l'air et dans ma tête c'est
vraiment très franchement il est bien
fait bon j'avoue comment tu fais la
tactique en dtm et tu vas me laisser ça
méritait un petit but avant moi je dis
que non ce n'est pas enflé de tous les
cas tâche est fatigués en plus j'ai eu
un poste où aller c'était à moi de faire
la pole j'ai pas les skis racé moteur de
collision c'était sur la paix comedy
club ça sort c'est là où les mecs tomber
en asie le texte
oui l aller et là j'ai vu l'ouverture et
là j'ai vu l'ouverture et là je vois le
sandre et là je vole tout la wii
oui parce que je regarde au ralenti
célia au [ __ ] un satellite à souhait
c'était une retournée non olala à
messieurs dames hausse était mannequin à
l'équitation je mettrai une petite
musique d'ambiance
kawata c'était trop de partis
ayari fait des gros blanc mais jean
laffon d'honneur
ah je m'en fous et mon fils c'était plus
beaux ya rien à dire pour moi ya des
hommes et non mais si j'ai marqué un but
l'honneur et sommet donc tu as on
regarde la haye regarde là tu vois
l'ouverture à 9 gardes up ouverture
d'actifs en fait c'est une petite faim
grâce à sa jupe en montrant la balle
avec ce joueur si l'un parce qu'il a su
ajouter dessus
[Musique]
genre
sa mère g si elles chutent avis oui
allez passez moi ça c'est bientôt fini
on espère que ces petits galets gameplay
puisque très bonne partie de ma part on
va dire vous a bien plu et donc voilà je
vais et voilà et donc voilà on espère
que cette petite vidéo sur deux vous ah
ouais attention je me tue musique danse
a plu je met une petite musique
d'ambiance histoire du passé vont pas
trop chez vol quelques sessions tous les
genres y ait cette attaque les bons
attendu au oui l'ouverture l'ouverture
version leurs tirs il a fait quoi tu la
mets un coup physique [ __ ] est plein
on espère marquer c'est le mental ça tu
vois c'est de la grosse arnaque jésus
[Applaudissements]
non mais arrête quoi
comme ça se passe
non mais rennes antoine c'est pas sympa
pour ceux qui regardent arrête les
regarde oui les quotas aller avec vous
j'aimerais bien que le pc crash comme ça
hop et aucune preuve alors là c'est la
fin d'un teint dans matcher on s'enlève
me away
et ben voilà qu'à deux pour moi aussi
j'ai pris pas un c'est pas toi qui joues
être marseille non c'est moi qui pose
ici je parle là de magma écouter jean
j'espère ce qui fut pas vous aura plus
fins et j'essaierai de calais avec de la
musique on se retrouve dans un instant
pour une nouvelle vidéo ou ne pas
assister la dernière que voulait mater
ou si c'est la première on verra bien
seul au milieu a tout de suite tout le
monde bat bisou à plus
[Musique]